This last spring
I was commissioned an essay by Bishop Barron's word on fire
journal
Which comes out quarterly and they were putting out an issue on faith and film so they asked me to write an essay
For it. I asked him if I could read the essay for you, and they said that it would be fine
And so I'm going to read this essay because I think I was really able to concisely
put together my vision of how
Culture can be healed or how we can integrate healthy culture
And as we just saw in the last few weeks we saw Jordan Peterson reappear
We were happy to see that he is seems to be doing a little better. And so it's also an opportunity for me to
frame my relationship with him in terms of thought what are the similarities and
especially what are the differences that separate Jordan and I in our perception of how to
engage to heal to deal with a
difficulty in modern culture
This is Jonathan pezzo, welcome to the symbolic world
The world is suddenly keen on storytelling
After a few decades of the new atheist assault of the postmodern undermining and fragmentation of identities of the venomous
insistence that all that makes us human is a social construct as opposed to the objectivity of the scientists a
strange post atheistic professor from Toronto has shaken the core of
secularists discourse of
Course, there are those Bishop Baron among them who have been hacking at the question of narrative for a while
but as I stood there at a Toronto bus station late one evening in the fall of
2016 I knew that the moment and the character I was facing were different
After a goodbye hug and a pause. I looked at Jordan Peterson and said
You're gonna bring back Christianity
His surprised reaction betrayed hesitation followed by his secular alternative
Hopefully we can get people to understand the psychological significance of these Bible stories. I
Was unsettled by his answer and it still rings in my ear to this day
and now four years later in the wake of Jordan Peterson's rise to worldwide fame and after a
bewildering cascade of YouTube videos interviews
lectures debates and a surprising tectonic shift in the discourse about religion
It seems the issue is still playing out
Which one of the two options?
Jordans prediction or mine will come out on top of
Course a return to Christianity and the discovery of the deep
Profundity of its stories are not exclusive to each other
Any thoughtful Christian knows of the psychological Keys offered up in the Bible
Yet to communicate the relevance of our faith
It is incumbent on us to celebrate not only the psychological depths of Scripture
But also its cosmic and metaphysical fullness
We should not only remember and reinterpret the ancient narrative
but lead our former detractors by the hand grand anse of our liturgy our art our
architecture and our pious legends
It has been given to us to show the world how all these modern stories these novels
We read and these movies we watch are useful
but the most powerful stories are those we live and participate in
Surprisingly facing the current social breakdown of meaning and identity in the West
the Christian story presents itself once again as the only viable solution to the widening gyre
The only meta narrative that makes sense of it all
Christians should not underestimate the power of our story and the liberation it provides in the midst of a rising nihilism
While modern scientists and philosophers are wrestling with questions of complexity and emergence
meaning is reappearing as
imperative for the world's existence and
meaning making no longer appears as a
Superstitious man. Oh we can discard
mind essence and logos
But also in turn incarnation of principles like story body and image all shine in our strange
historical moment as the very keys to how reality unfolds
But before we take on the mysteries of the cosmos
The Christian story first has the power to liberate the body of Christ from the yoke of so-called critical scholarship
what I call story and what our ancestors called tradition is this golden thread of narrative people intention and
spirit that can free us from the scholars autopsy of Scripture
Which has culminated into the sterile Jesus Seminar and celebrity atheist Bible scholars
Let us remember and celebrate the story of Christ
Not the story limited to Christ's red letter statements and to the burden of scholarly approval but rather
the story that animated the medieval Mystery Plays
The one that spans from the first word of creation to humankind made in the image the fall the covenants the law
The carnation the death and resurrection the ascension into heaven
The sitting on the right hand of the Father and the coming again in glory to judge the living and the dead
that story is the culmination and
condensation of all
storytelling
Firstly because it is the meta story it is about how meaning
Logos is the source of reality and how it fills doubts and questions with a full yet adapted answer
It is the ultimate story because it manifests the most pristine example of descent and ascent
The universal u-shaped story described to us by modern scholars from Frazer to Northrop Frye
The u-shaped structure is found in the story of Jesus Christ through death and resurrection
But is ultimately a cosmic story spanning from the garden and the fall to the holy city
Christ as the personal embodiment of the cosmic story also blends together all the aspects of the human archetype
he is the type of all story characters for each presented as priest as king as
warrior as artisan as
servant as
pastor as
gardener both solar and Reaper as
prophet as teacher as healer as
virgin as
bridegroom as judge as victim as
outcast as criminal as
scandal as
Descending to the lowest rung of hell and ascending to the right hand of the Father
He is the Creator who becomes the creature
He is Adam who allows himself to be overwhelmed by the serpent for our sake he is life
That becomes death light that becomes darkness alpha to Omega all in order to saturate the entire
Cosmos and meta-narrative with the fullness of its origin and to change even death into glory
To recover the ancient story we must first recover its scope in
Recent decades. We have seen Christians attempt to connect to a secular world that has progressed we broken from their embrace
popular culture since the Renaissance has grown from neutrally secular to openly hostile against Christianity as
rebellion
individualism and the dismantling of authority had become the main tropes of both the subject and forms of culture and
Everything from avant-garde art to rock and roll. We have seen Christians running up to catch up with secular culture our
efforts are usually mediocre in the
empty quest for innovation and individual creativity the last century has left us with a
wasteland of bad church architecture bad liturgical art bad
Music but also a slew of humdrum attempts from Christians to make secular art as well
But as the explicitly Christian iconography and narrative recede from the public space
Their implicit structures begin to emanate in a strange dim glow
Which appears stronger as the main light fades and so it is as Christianity is set aside
We can never nevertheless see the story of the resurrection
everywhere in popular culture the knock down hero getting up at the last moment has become such a standard pattern of
Popular movies and fiction that we fail to recognize what it owes
to the synthesis of that pattern in the story of Christ
Watching rocky or Thor or neo get beaten down for several minutes until it becomes unbearable
Only to see the hero rise in victory at the end has become a permanent pattern of storytelling
even beyond the acts of a protagonist
When imposes itself in the modern hero is a Christian Knight who sacrifices himself to help the weak and the helpless
the
Heroes and gods of old like Hercules or Achilles like Odin and Thor acted out of a desire to obtain riches and glory
To defend their own clans or at best to acquire wisdom for themselves
Although there are some hints or pre figurations of self-sacrifice in antiquity
The death of Socrates be seen through that angle
It is truly in Christ that this trope becomes the narrative pattern for our modern heroes in
the conclusion of Marvel's Avengers
Epic the series finds its climax in the moment where Tony Stark's succeeds in using the power of the Infinity Gauntlet
The weapon wielded by Thanos in order to turn it against Thanos and thereby annul the power of death
We had seen this moment before in modern narrative
The power of the gauntlet is the power of the One Ring in tokine's epoch
Forged by the evil Lord Sauron the ring holds untold power in
The Lord of the Rings several important characters are tempted to use its power for good
Yet we discover how the absolute power of the Ring would corrupt the user and turn them into the very tyrant
They wish to oppose
Why then is it different for Tony Stark to take the gauntlet from Thanos
What narrative change may the Avengers climax so successful?
The answer is a Christian one
It is because the act of wielding this absolute power was also an act of self-sacrifice
It is because Tony Stark consented to die so that he could defeat death by death
the story of Tony Stark a selfish arrogant
Billionaire reaching the end of his narrative arc by sacrificing himself to save mankind is a story that is impossible
without Christ
The story of Christ is everywhere
it fills our novels our movies our comic books and TV shows it fills our political and family narratives and it even
frames our self perception a
worldview without Christ is one that can barely be imagined anymore only maybe in the guise of its inversion the
antihero and Antichrist who cannot help despite himself to point at what is
inverted
Although it may seem like an aporia to some
And it's very eraser from the common discourse even
As it is being shooed from the public sphere we can see how the story of Christ will inevitably
Return in its fullness. I
Say this not as a vague prophecy or a sentimental desire
but rather as the
inevitable playing out of a pattern as
Common as the waning and waxing of the moon of the moon or the setting and rising of the Sun
the meta-narrative
embodied in the crucifixion will also play itself out in the story of Christianity as the
cosmic body of Christ Christ reaches the resolution of its own story in
February of this year the film director and universal geek Kevin Smith tweeted out something fascinating
Religions quote religions have been founded on the Bible resulted in millions of people deriving
Inspiration and moral strength from amazing stories about fantastic feats of faith
Hundreds of years from now our descendants will find divine inspiration from the story of CAP wielding Mjolnir and quote
He was referring to a scene in Avengers endgame where Captain America picks up Thor's hammer and uses it to fight with Thanos
Something which is supposed to happen only in the hands of a God worthy of the weapon
the tweet exposes many things simultaneously
First it shines a light on how there is an explicit attempt in recent large-scale movies to use highly
mytho religious language in their storytelling
Second it suggests. These stories are on par with the ancient ones and are set to replace them
For someone in the comic book and movie industry to proclaim this so explicitly
Something that had been a nebulous speculation on the part of us watching culture
Simultaneously exposes the shallowness and impossibility of such a proposition
It is one thing to see the analogy between these entertainment ventures and the stories that really matter
It is another to declare the Disney comic book characters will replace religion
May seem that I'm snubbing my nose at popular entertainment, but that's not the point
The problem with the superhero movie is not in its capacity to embody or not
the cosmic patterns it is in how there exists a fundamental difference between
entertainment and active life
The story of Christ and even the ancient myths were not just stories people told
To entertain each other to make people think or even to inspire action
certainly, these ancient stories could do all of that, but mostly the ancient stories were our
Stories the stories of who we are why we are here where we are going
The story of Christ is what we are meant to enter into
To be baptized into Christ to put on Christ to become the image of Christ
The communion of the saint and the tradition of the Apostles are an actual
Thread of people and stories that link us to Christ and to our ancestors
Their stories are our stories
We're not
We not only speak
Them but celebrate them
Not on not naming our cities and our children after these people
The Saints are present to us. We ask them to pray for us and with them
we celebrate and worship Christ and whose story we are all called to be glorified and
so when we point to the new stories and
Enjoy how they embody some aspect of the great pattern how they embody this or that aspect of Christ
everything flows in the right direction
But when the opposite happens and we suggest that these new stories could act as a replacement
for the Christian story
Then all the superficial qualities of these new stories come to the fore and they appear as empty vessels
None of us can live in the trademark and copyrighted Marvel Universe
Even if Disney builds a theme park for us
None of us can point to the place where Ironman was martyred or display the hammer picked up by Captain
erricka in the famous battle of endgame these fictional stories are only
Liminal their power on us can only awaken a desire to live in our own story
but the story of Christ and His Saints a
Very cosmic story from creation to the eschaton is the one in which we live every day
it is the story that we celebrate during our liturgies that marks our space through sacred sites that marks our year with feasts and
processions
The secular world has tried to replace all of this
But its efforts only feed the fragmentation and leveling tendency of modernity
And so we all Teeter on the shore of deep nihilism as the waves get higher and the storm comes closer
Finally
We should not take lightly the powerful shift in culture that has taken place since the then-unknown professor in Toronto
spoke out against mandatory speech requirements
Yet in the wake of the quote Jordan Peterson movement as
I pray for the health and recovery of my friend
I feel it is nonetheless my role to say we must reach further
It is not enough to understand stories
Psychologically, and it is not enough to be upstanding individuals
It is not enough to live by stories. We must live in them
The stories must be a path. We walk part of the glue that holds us together and
Individuals must unite themselves to a body
Well-formed in love so that we grow up into the logos himself. Who is the head?
Without that extra step we will ultimately be dispersed like smoke like wax before the fire